hello everyone i'm maurice samuels the
director of the yale program for the
study of anti-semitism and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you to our first
talk of the
2021-22 academic year in our benjamin
and barbara zucker lecture series i
could not have asked for a better
speaker to start things off
jeffrey herbst is the president of the
american jewish university in los
angeles california and has previously
served as the president of colgate
university as president of the newseum
in washington dc and is provost of miami
university he's a professor of political
science specializing in comparative
politics and is the author of state
politics in zimbabwe 1990 and states in
power in africa comparative lessons in
authority and control of 2000 which
received the luberd best book award in
comparative politics from the american
political science association
i should add that jeffrey herbst is a
yale alum he received he received his
phd from yale in 1987. and when i read
the thoughtful and thought-provoking
article on campus anti-semitism that he
published this summer in inside higher
ed and i saw that he had gone to yale i
realized that he would be the perfect
person to help us think through the
question of how to talk about middle
east politics on campus in this time of
escalating conflict as some of you know
this talk is all the more timely after
the recent discovery of racist and
anti-semitic graffiti on the yale campus
this past week
so here's how
excuse me things will work
president herbst will speak for about 30
or 40 minutes after which you will take
questions from the audience so please
submit your questions at any time during
the talk using the q a button at the
bottom of your screen
and then i will ask those questions
anonymously the chat function is
disabled so please don't use that and we
will end
at 6 pm
the title of today's talk is
anti-semitism and free speech on college
campuses please join me in welcoming
jeffrey herbs
professor samuels thank you so very much
it's a pleasure to speak to a yale
audience i wish i could be in new haven
but i'm grateful that we have the
technology that allows me to address you
on this important topic
i situate myself in this discussion
i am a jew who is concerned of course
about anti-semitism and as professor
samuel said i am president of a
faith-based institution and have been a
college administrator for some time i'm
also the former head of the museum in
washington d.c a cultural institution
that was based on the first amendment so
not only do i have
an appreciation of the value of our free
speech protections but i have
consistently argued that the solution to
bad speech is more speech i still
believe that even when there is an issue
such as anti-semitism that i'm
personally concerned with
of course the free speech protections of
the first amendment technically do not
apply to private colleges such as yale
because the free speech guarantees in
the constitution are protections from
government censorship
however i think we would all agree that
yale and other private colleges aspire
to the same free speech climate that is
constitutionally guaranteed in public
schools
and just to be clear to make it even
more complicated a significant amount of
what people consider to be hate speech
including some anti-semitic remarks are
contrary to public belief
constitutionally protected the ability
to ban speech is constricted and depends
on the immediacy and specificity of the
threat
that being said of course there's a
great deal of difference about what you
can say and what you should say
finally i approach this topic gingerly
especially as much of it will focus on
anti-semitism and relationship to
ongoing debates about the middle east
because charges and discussions about
anti-semitism can sometimes take all the
oxygen out of the room
and
cause us to avoid other issues
for instance in the case of nicholas
kristoff the new york times
correspondent who's argued albeit in an
attentive manner that israel should not
defend itself from hamas rocket attacks
kristoff defends himself by saying and
it's not anti-semitic to criticize
israel for possible war crimes it's not
but it's also could just be wrong uh and
the fact that critics can sometimes be
wrong but not by the anti-semitic is
sometimes missed
finally in this discussion i think the
stakes are actually even higher
than for people including jews but not
limited of course who are worried about
anti-semitism or people who want to
debate the middle east
residential colleges such as yale along
with military bases despite their many
problems are among the most diverse
residential settings in the united
states in an increasingly polarized and
segmented society
residential colleges have a bedrock
commitment to making all feel part of
their community and to free speech even
if one or both of those core commitments
are violated in practice
if there cannot be open passionate
debate about israel and u.s foreign
policy in the middle east without
lurching into anti-semitism then i'm
afraid there's not much hope for a good
debate in the rest of our society
if on the other hand as i hope and as
i'll argue throughout this talk colleges
and universities can model what civil
discourse actually means
then i think there is hope for the rest
of the society also debating these
issues in a manner that's constructive
of course israel has been a contentious
issue on college campuses for decades
when i was a student at princeton in the
early 1980s
israel had invaded lebanon lebanon and
there was enormous amount of controversy
about those actions
however
i was at that time and for years after
relatively sanguine about the atmosphere
for jewish students on most colleges
college campuses indeed a decade ago i
was giving talks where i argued contrary
to growing fears at the time that
anti-semitism on college campuses was
not that much of a problem outside of a
relatively few large public
universities i wasn't wrong i believe at
the time but i think the situation has
changed and i'm concerned now very
concerned
the indicators regarding college
anti-semitism have been flashing red for
some time pillow reported that
anti-semitic incidents on college
campuses rose to an all-time high in
2000 1920 even with the closure of many
due to the pandemic there's been a
constant drum beat of anti-semitic
incidents
that have grown disheartening at the
university of southern california a
jewish student was forced to resign as
vice president of the student government
after her
harassment because of her pro-israel
views
at arizona state university hitler rose
right posters have been taken down
several times at the university of
connecticut there have been repeated
incidents of anti-semitic graffiti and
verbal insults of the type that
professors samuels reported on the yale
campus just this week
a new poll surveying members of a
leading predominantly jewish fraternian
sorority found that more than 65 of the
respondents have felt unsafe on campus
due to anti-semitic attacks with one in
10 reporting that they have feared
physical assault because they are openly
jewish
additionally nearly 70 percent of
students said they had personally
experienced or were familiar with an act
of anti-semitism on campus or in a
virtual campus setting in the last 120
days
as a result and this is particularly
disheartening about 50 said they had
hidden their jewish identities and more
than half have have
avoided expressing their views on israel
that's terrible
both for the students involved and for
all of us who hope that a college campus
will be welcoming safe and openly
vibrant for all students
more generally
across jewish communities in north
america
there is a real fear today about the
collegiate environment that jewish
students and supporters of israel face
this has been fed by a constant group of
stories about physical confrontations
that jewish students have had as well as
a feeling that college administrators
have not treated anti-semitism with the
same seriousness that they address other
forms of hatred
pains me to say this but today i was
talking to a friend and i was telling
her that i was giving a talk
to a yale audience and she told me that
recently
her daughter
had been advised by a college counselor
not to apply to yale
because it had a difficult environment
for jewish students
now
i know it's very difficult to place one
story in any particular context and i
know there's a lot of disinformation out
there and i see no data that yale is
actually more hostile to jewish students
than any other campus or certainly its
competitors
however that is the kind of story and
that is the kind of discussion that is
out there uh and that is now being
entertained by lawrence kartz of the
jewish community that would i think have
been um inconceivable a decade ago so i
think the concern should be very real
now why is all this happening
part of it that situation in the united
states is becoming more polarized
public expressions of hatred towards
many different groups are increasing and
this inevitably falls partially to the
jews according to recent fbi statistics
american jews who make up no more than 2
percent of the u.s population are
targets of nearly 60 percent of
religious bias
anti-semitism on college campuses
has in particular morphed over time from
old stereotypes about jews to collateral
damage from heated discussions about
israel palestine the middle east and the
united states role in that region
this is somewhat different than debates
in the public outside of colleges where
old stereotypes of jews still often
dominate
anti-semitic attacks
and certainly we saw in the
upsurge in violence against jews
across u.s cities in may as a result of
the gaza conflict that there is a
continuing rise of anti-semitism
and this has this placed back on college
campuses where the dynamic about heated
debates about the middle east
turning into sometimes anti-semitic
attacks has been a primary concern to
jewish students
what else is different i think is that
the institutional settings of debate
about israel palestine the middle east
the united states role is being
challenged and i think this is a
particular concern to people as myself
who both value a safe environment for
all students and one which is
one which
promotes free speech
opponents of israel have taken as a
strategy from migrating from individual
voice which i view as protected and
often welcome to demanding that
institutions on college campuses take
positions something that i view as
frightening and quite often
inappropriate here i'll focus in part on
the yale campus both because i'm
nominally speaking uh to a yale audience
and because as professor samuels noted
i'm an alum of that of this institution
but also because what's playing out on
the yale campus is playing out on many
other college campuses across this
country
now of course many scholars no doubt
including summit yale have signed
letters in their personal capacity
strongly opposing israel during the gods
of violence i can argue with these
individuals who by believe are sometimes
right sometimes wrong sometimes
misinformed sometimes anti-semitic
however they're using their voice to
express their individual opinion and i
or others in the community are free to
disagree with them on an equal playing
field
while i might regret personally their
views i defend their right in most cases
to have them and i look forward to
debating them
however what has changed is that now
some institutions on college campuses
are being asked to take positions as was
noted widely on your campus in june
the yale college council adopted a
statement of condemnation of israel that
noted in part as yale students we
condemn the injustice ethnic cleansing
and genocide occurring in palestine and
continued just as israel's military
imposes the apartheid system against
palestinians the u.s police enforced the
system of white supremacy against black
americans
now i view those statements as
exceptionally problematic because i do
not believe and i can argue this at
greater length
that ethnic cleansing or genocide in
fact characterizes what is going on in
israel and the palestinian territories
and as someone who observed firsthand
whose study wrote about apartheid in
south africa i do not believe that is an
application where arab israelis have
full political rights in israel and
where there is now our political party
and the ruling coalition
i don't know the exact origins of their
resolution and i would surmise that
there was a fair amount of virtue
signaling and other politicking i do
know that it was unfortunate
because i think that a student
government could have done a good turn
in setting parameters for an open
free
fierce debate about israel but instead
went in another direction and in fact
closing off debate and adopting a
position which it knew many students
would disagree with or feel comfortable
with
still these are young people and as
deborah lipstaff the bush the biden
administration's nominee for a special
envoy to fight anti-semitism has noted
when looking at anti-semites we should
differentiate between the simple one and
the wicked one as regrettable as the
student government's views were i'm
under no illusion that students
governments are particularly important
and have much of a power to structure
conversation on campus it is certainly
possible of course that this statement
could feel threatening to individual
students jewish or non-jewish who are
supportive as in israel who are
supporters of israel and that would be
unfortunate more likely it's like it
will lead to the delegitimization of the
student government itself
of course there's not much the yale
administration could have done about
what the student government proclaims it
could have issued a statement contrary
but i understand why administrators
might be reluctant to react to every
student government statement
more problematic in my view were some
faculty statements that have emerged
from particular programs
the faculty and ethnicity race and
migration issued a statement on
palestine on may 17th that said as
scholars in the program we recognize the
palestinians struggle as an indigenous
liberation movement confronting a
settler colonial state illegally
expropriating their land for over 70
years
members of the yale program went on to
say we express solidarity with the
palestinian people as they resist the
many forms of israeli state violence and
fight for their freedom we will amplify
the voices of palestinian scholars and
center the anti-colonial struggles in
our academic and political practice
no talk here of course to return to the
1967 lines or anything else this is
about the delegitimization of israel and
the promotion of a particular
perspective and as they say their
academic and public practice
similarly the yale's women gender and
sexuality studies program signed a
letter also endorsed by dozens of other
women's and gender studies programs
across the country titled gender studies
departments in solidarity with
palestinian feminist collective
that among other things endorse the
unambiguous right of return
for palestinians which depending on what
this actually means would amount to the
destruction of israel as a jewish state
further the letter said we do not
subscribe to a quote both sides unquote
rhetoric that erases the military
economic media and global power that
israel has over palestine this is not a
conflict in quotes that is too
controversial and complex in quotes to
assess
i'll get to the substantive issues with
regard to israel in a moment but i think
stepping back from israel and
anti-semitism
that these statements are exceptionally
problematic for a number of reasons
speech and debate the very things that
these programs and others at a
university were designed to encourage
are being stifled here i'm concerned
about the boundaries of free speech
being curtailed because those who have
the power and make no mistake
the professors and faculty in these
programs speak from a privileged
position in the hierarchy of yale are
pre-determining the outcome of certain
intellectual debates indeed they are
delegitimizing anyone who has an
opposing view
the no less than the american
association of university professors in
its 1940
a profound statement on principles on
economic and freedom and tenure to find
the prevailing professional standards of
academic freedom of faculty it stated as
scholars and educational officers they
teachers should remember that the public
may judge their profession and their
institution by their utterances hence
they should at all times be average
should exercise appropriate restraint
show
show should jokes respect for the
opinion of others and should make every
effort to indicate that they are not
speaking for the institution
academic is a one freedom is a wonderful
thing but it
comes with certain profound
responsibilities
the implications of programs taking on
political positions is that certain
types of research and outcomes are
privileged as well as implications for
hiring and teachers
teaching at its basis i think this is
profoundly anti-intellectual by not only
arguing that the other side is wrong but
stating really there is no other side
now i would say the exact same thing if
an east asian studies department issued
proclamations about genocide against the
uyghurs even though i personally believe
that genocide is being conducted by
beijing but i don't believe it's the
role of an academic department
to take on political positions that
changed the contours of the free speech
debate on campus
i headed the department of politics at
princeton for five years which i believe
is a distinguished academic unit and i
also have a lot of firm and deeply held
political beliefs it would never
occurred to me frankly to get to the
department to endorse the positions i
had both because i didn't believe that
others necessarily believed them and i
would have been worried on the
implications for students graduate
student
departmental research and the
intellectual climate that the department
was supposed to foster
jewish students and those who may who
are pro-israel could legitimately
complain i think that these
proclamations and others cause a
threatening environment
i have no idea about the individual
sentiments of the faculty who have
signed these proclamations but i know
that these kinds of statements by
delegitimizing certain intellectual
positions provide an environment for
attack on supporters of interested rail
inevitably
because their positions are seen as
illegitimate
attacks which converge on or leap over
to anti-semitism
and of course balance to support the
resistance
without differentiation of the
palestinians is not even a veiled
endorsement of hamas it is an
endorsement of hamas and its decision to
rain rockets down on israelis both jews
and palestinians
it would have been easier to
differentiate
some sort of support
vis-a-vis some sorts of resistance but
that was not done
leading these programs to implicitly
endorse the proudly anti-semitic
organization hamas that has at its
fundamental charter calling for the
destruction of the jewish state
now it's my understanding although i'm
not well aware of the campus environment
that many at yale have not spoken out
against these programs that they meant
to be thought
despite the fact that i believe that
they are significant departures from
academic standards i view that as
unfortunate as someone who believes that
ethnicity race migration and gender are
critically important to understand and
who has tried to contribute in some of
those areas and as a college
administrator i would say then when you
do not engage with colleagues who you
believe have violated the norms of the
university you are essentially
marginalizing them by essentially not
taking them seriously enough to disagree
as another yali has said
those who do not confront these programs
are guilty of the soft bigotry of low
expectations
why have universities had such trouble
dealing with anti-semitism and why is
there such concern among jewish students
and significant worry that the problem
will get worse in the coming years
despite the fact that many universities
with the best of intentions including
yale have devoted enormous resources to
student affairs offices to diversity to
bias training and the like
part of the answer is that
fighting hatred fighting bigotry on
campuses is hard and i recognize that
full stop
but there are also other issues that are
specific to
anti-semitism
jewish students are often coded as white
by student affairs officers and by
others
seen as a privileged portion of society
the fact that these students may be
vulnerable to anti-semitic attacks is
not put on the same plane of concern
as possibilities of bigotry and hatred
devoted against communities of color
who have of course endured a tremendous
amount of bigotry and hatred this is
despite the fact that the recently
released pew study on american jewry
found that 15 of jews under the age of
30
might reasonably include the college
population identify hispanic black asian
or multi-racial
of course no students should be subject
to hatred or bigotry but the fact that
jews are not coded as among those groups
who are traditionally been the recipient
of tremendous hatred and bigotry
produces i would argue some dissonance
and collegiate approaches to how to deal
with the problem
it's also the case that some portion but
by no means all of the anti-semitic
attacks on jewish students and
who are supporters of israel come from
people who are involved in communities
of color and who college administrators
code as always being the recipients of
hatred and bigotry and not necessarily
as the perpetrators
what to do
the common answer
is always more speech that's been my
answer uh for a long time
but
isn't what i'm saying is that there is
too much focus on israel right now and
the sheer focus is part of what's
propelling anti-semitism
i don't believe that and i'm fine with a
lot of focus on israel but i think it
has to be done with nuance and with care
although it's obvious it is worth saying
that not every criticism of israel is
anti-semitic there are plenty of
legitimate criticisms and although
heroic powerful voices like natan
sharonsky have argued that as
anti-semitic if israel is treated in a
fundamentally different manner i'm not
even sure of that
on some level it's true of course but i
don't take it that israel
should
but i take it that israel should be held
to a higher standard than syria or other
countries in the middle east because of
its own self-professed norms it wants to
be held to a higher standards and yes
because it is a major u.s aid recipient
however that makes it special but not
unique a differentiation that is
important
and i'm not sure why there is an
additional speech on other issues
take for instance ethiopia a country
that i've studied that's part of my own
academic work
ethiopia is a country that the us has
given 13 billion dollars in aid over the
last 20 years and that received until
the recent civil war began around 3.5
billion dollars in porn assistance from
major donors each year including another
significant share from multilateral
institutions which americans in part
share
because of the civil war instigated in
good part by the federal government and
artists
over four hundred thousand people
according to a recent report by the
council on foreign relations in degrade
province are living in famine conditions
79 percent of pregnant and lactating
women screened over the course of a week
were found to suffer from acute
malnutrition and only eleven percent of
the humanitarian supplies needed in the
region have actually been delivered
since july delivery of medical supplies
to t-ray is prohibited by the ethiopian
government as is the delivery of fuel
making distribution of aid that does not
that does make into the region
extraordinarily difficult
now i'm not saying of course that you
cannot talk about israel if you don't
talk about ethiopia
what i am saying is there should be more
talk about ethiopia and in particular
understanding that the world is a
complicated place
if you come to an understanding and a
critique of israel after
at least some review of what is
happening in the rest of the world then
you have a potentially respectable
position or at least one that can be
argued with however if you immediately
look at israel's uniquely bad without
understanding how the world works then
that is something else the yale college
council has not taken a thundering
declaration on t gray and women's
studies programs do not talk about women
in tigre
even closer to home i often wonder about
the focus on israel
here i'll talk briefly about the biden
and obama administrations
i'll give trump for the moment only
because the two others are the ones
likely to supported by a good part of
the audience
president biden's administration killed
zamari ahmadi it's important to say his
name
by a drone in afghanistan after he was
going around kabul collecting water
bottles seven children were killed in
collateral damage because of that drone
attack
yet there has not been a demand for war
crimes trial
for a military that killed a person of a
color i can only imagine if netanyahu
had done this
more generally according to the bureau
of investigative journalism a total of
563
strikes largely by drones targeted
pakistan somali and yemen during obama's
two terms about ten times as many as
under bush between 384 and 800 civilians
were killed in those countries according
to reports logged by the bureau and of
course those countries unlike gaza and
israel
did not provide any direct threat to the
united states
and i've been struck by the fact that
there's often more debate about the
israeli conduct of conflict in the
united states than there has been about
the american conduct of conflict
although you would think that americans
are most concerned about the governments
that they themselves elect directly
now why is this
well lots of people are passionate about
israel and palestine i get that
it's easier to cover gaza than it is
yemen
that's an issue
some americans are more interested in
criticizing netanyahu who is still prime
minister in the last gaza conflict than
in the old leaders that they support
that's less okay i think
hamas has made a technical a tactical
decision to make its people vulnerable
and then use their deaths as
delegitimating the israeli right to
defense
it has its fellows it has its supporters
and its fellow travelers who have fallen
in with this media strategy
and then the israel conflict has been
used the israel conflict with
palestinians
has been used to link to u.s conflict
from minneapolis to palestine as the
documents the yale students published
say
i don't want to spend too much time on
this issue but i'll say as someone who's
done field work
in
countries with conflicts
that participants on the ground
understand their conflicts according to
their own circumstances
without reference to minnesota or
anywhere else you demean local
participants both israelis and
palestinians when you try to understand
them by placing them in your conflict
so
and then there are of course
outright anti-semites who jump all over
any controversy about israel uh to feed
in their own bigotry
what is clear is there's a whole range
of mixed motives when there's more
speech about israel
some of it
a large part of it i would argue is good
some of it is problematic
what i do believe what i am in favor of
is when people such as myself say more
speech
we really should say more careful speech
i'm not interested in censoring anyone
but i am interested in encouraging
everyone to spend the time to understand
the nuances and complexities of yes all
sides of a conflict and to try to put
them into the context of the way the
world operates
the game
the political discussion has to be on an
even keo that's why i'm somewhat
concerned about student government who
can poison collegiate atmospheres but
i'm very concerned about academic
programs and institutions that could
serve as a venue for arguments not as a
vector for particular opinions and who
develop in fact consciously
anti-intellectual stances these programs
and departments go against the very idea
of the more careful speech which i'm
trying to promote
to conclude i'll say that anti-semitism
is a problem that suggests that all data
suggests is going to get worse on
society at large and on college campuses
it is going to be an ongoing concern and
not go away and we are on the verge as i
wrote in my article on august of some
potentially very serious incidents where
physical harm is done to students and
there's already a great deal of mental
and emotional anguish
colleges and universities should go out
of their way to be proven grounds to
show how difficult issues which people
feel passionately about can be discussed
without bigotry and animus instead
they're going in the opposite direction
and maybe the places where israel and
the middle east are least likely to be
productively discussed
i think that would be unfortunate i
think college administrators should go
out of their way to socialize their
colleagues that anti-semitism is a real
issue that bigotry can affect even those
populations who may be coded as
privileged
and that administrators are going to
have to do a tremendous amount of work
and exert significant political capital
to make sure that the speech environment
on their campuses remains free and fair
if we can do that if we can figure out a
way to discuss these issues uh without
bigotry then i believe that colleges and
universities can reassert their stature
as the primary intellectual centers of
american life and model to a society
which is polarized divided and which is
rife with bigotry and hatred
how discussions can happen i'm not sure
that will occur on all campuses but
across the 4 000 colleges and
universities in the united states i hope
that these issues so vitally important
to israelis palestinians jews non-jews
and a great many other people across the
world can be developed in a way that
people feel is productive
important and free of fear and hostility
professor samuels let me stop there as i
said i'm honored to be able to talk with
you delighted to be able to address
these subjects happy to answer any
questions that the audience may have
okay terrific thank you uh jeffrey uh
we're really very grateful for that
really lucid um and nuanced presentation
and i'm sure they're going to be a lot
of questions um there already uh are
some i asked just to remind everybody to
please submit your questions using the q
a function
and i will ask them anonymously um so
while those are coming in i did have uh
a few questions of my own to to get us
going um first of all i you know i was
wondering if you could just go back to
what you the way you started uh the the
presentation uh with the question of
freedom of speech because i think that
that is something that people find
confusing and especially um the
distinction between public and private
universities is there any difference in
what kind of speech is you know
protected and not
the first amendments begins with
congress shall make no law so it applies
to government censorship and it's been
understood that it applies to public
universities that are part of the
american state
so formally the first amendment applies
to
public universities but
i i'm sure my colleagues at yale and
every place else certainly i felt this
way at colgate and princeton uh believe
that
everyone on those campuses should have
the same
rights of expression that are formally
guaranteed
when i was at miami university in ohio a
public university
so i think
the constitution may be one thing but i
think the norms
that have been adopted
certainly suggests that private
universities aspire to the same
free speech
environments that public universities
are required to have
okay thank you for that so here's uh a
question that i had but i i hear it
echoed in some of the questions um from
the audience
um
can you
be a little more specific about um
why those statements by the yale college
council or by the ethnicity race and
migration um i we understand why you
think it's problematic but can you um be
a little more specific about whether and
why you think that they're anti-semitic
so in other words where is that
you know this is another way of asking
the question where is the line between
um anti-zionism and anti-semitism i hope
i was uh nuanced enough in my
presentation i
said that they can enable an environment
where attacks on supporters of israel
converge on or lurch over to
anti-semitism
that's the important issue to me because
first of all those statements change the
level playing field that individuals
have in debating these issues and second
they go out of their way
they were quite striking i thought and
delegitimizing
the other side it's not they said we
think that the other side is wrong on
the facts or on the data or on our
opinion they said it's illegitimate uh
to have a different opinion uh and the
first statement also said uh some things
about privileging uh certain
perspectives in the academic practice
that has
i'm not saying that that per se is
anti-semitic what i am saying is that
enables anti-semitic an anti-semitic
environment and i think is before we
even get to anti-semitism just
exceptionally problematic in terms of
academic practice
okay um
so
uh
another question that you know as
someone i think we both uh
went to college in the 80s when and you
referred to the um anti-apartheid
movement in the 80s and i think a lot of
people especially from our generation
but others have a hard time
understanding what the difference is
between you know uh
opposing apartheid in the 80s and
opposing um either just israel tukur or
um
you know the occupation let's say now
look i mean if you want to take a
position on israel and oppose the
occupation as an individual that's your
basis what i'm saying is that
i was not aware
uh when i was at princeton or yale when
i was a graduate student and uh
yale was
a center of southern african studies uh
in the 1980s at the heart of the at the
height of the apartheid conflict that
individual programs were taking
political positions
on this
yale's response to the divestment debate
uh in the 1980s with the wise one it
said we're not going to divest but we're
going to invest significant resources in
the study of southern africa and develop
what i believe was the premier center
for southern african studies at the time
i thought that was exactly right
what's
when you have programs and institutions
take an opinion i think that changes the
nature of discourse
and i think it can be read as part of
the politicalization of everything
that we see
fewer personal relationships friendships
across party lines of
fewer people trusting any source
from the other side uh and this
politicalization of everything also
fueled by social media in its own way
has
leached onto college campuses and it
it's a problem um and i think uh it's
one
irrespective i think
uh as i said of your opinion on israel
that i would hope people would find
problematic just like i said if
departments started taking positions on
other issues even issues i agree with
i would find it problematic
so
i i think to to play devil's advocate
and i have definitely heard um
this uh
you know argument from people involved
especially i think in um
uh
women gender and sexuality studies
ethnicity race and migration they would
say or i have heard some people say
that um
their scholarship is about
that kind of um direct political action
so they don't really acknowledge i think
a distinction between
you know their um
you know their their scholarship and
their advocacy let's say so how do you i
would say
their scholarship is their business uh
and their individual advocacy is their
business and they have the right uh to
pursue those intellectual and advocacy
paths absolutely
it's where you invoke institutional
authority
that i think the line has crossed
okay and what um there's an interesting
question from the audience about um
uh you know we there's been so much uh
in the news just this week about um the
influence of social media on these
questions so can you say something about
um the how social media platforms have
kind of driven the the kind of
polarization that we're seeing on
college campuses yeah
i
this is a generalization but i'll start
here
in the 1980s when the college democrats
and the college republicans on a
particular campus
had to
find someone to talk with and debate
they found each other and they debated
each other and maybe they agreed or
maybe they disagreed but they were
talking with each other and being human
beings they recognized each other's
humanity
and friendships and social ties
developed
now people can live if they're college
democrats or college republicans or
anything else in their own ecosystem on
social media
without anyone ever without finding
anyone who ever disagrees with them and
any reason to moderate your views
so the filter bubble of social media to
borrow from a well-known phrase i think
has caused the increasing polarization
of american society on just about every
issue
because the need to mediate positions
in order to be socially acceptable in
order to develop ties is no longer there
and in fact almost anyone with no matter
how extreme views can find others who
share those views uh when in the past uh
there might have been others out there
but they weren't in the same town
so social media which i have a
you know
at the museum i celebrated social media
as the greatest explosion of public
expression in human history
i still believe that uh and many
wonderful things have occurred
as another saying goes the people
formerly known as the audience now are
able to speak but
some of what the audience says we found
out some of what we've been
thinking privately
in some cases turns out to be
problematic and along with a great
increase in democratization has come
increased expressions of bigotry hatred
across many different levels expressions
of violence as well as the ability of
human traffickers um terrorists and
others to organize so
we have engaged and let's say over the
last 15 years
we've completely changed our method of
discourse
and it's not exactly surprising that
norms
haven't kept up
whether those norms will ever
reach uh where we are in public and
social media i don't know um i'd like to
think circling back to the topic that
colleges and universities can be
you know so it both works against uh the
corrosive effects of social media but
it's hard because our students are the
very ones who are most wired in and who
have now
you know in their short lives had lives
which have been completely dominated by
social media
okay thank you so um we're getting
really a lot of questions here so here's
an interesting one and one that um i've
faced before too uh certainly running a
program devoted to the study of
anti-semitism
do you do you think at all that um
the
calling out anti-semitism
can um
result
in shutting down dialogue uh on college
campus and how to negotiate that you
know how
yeah
yes
look
no one no side is right all the time
and there are certainly been accusations
of anti-semitism which are incorrect and
uh i'll say there have certainly been
people who have tried to use the uh
the weapon of anti-semitism to shut down
debate that's happened uh and it's a
possibility and as i noted at the
beginning of my talk you know sometimes
i'm ambivalent about talking about
anti-semitism because it immediately
sucks all the oxygen out of the room uh
because you can't argue well i just
disagree with you uh without going to uh
the anti-semitic problem
how to
how to negotiate that uh is very
difficult uh sharansky uh has a
three-part test i think that's
interesting in terms of how israel is
tweeted i um
i opted for something more ambiguous in
my talk frankly and i gave a lot of
thought to this in preparation uh for
this uh for this talk
i think it depends on
whether
those talking have
exhibited some kind of reasoned approach
to where they got to their position
that's hard that's easy to say and hard
to discern but i'm going to stick with
it for the moment because i'm not
willing to immediately shut down debate
i think that's bad
so i want to say i wanted to
challenge people to say
you know how did you get there
um you know what was that what was the
process uh that you got there and if we
can discuss that process which is a long
and difficult discourse then maybe i
still disagree with you but i respect
your sentiments and
i think that's the kind of discourse
that colleges and universities should be
especially good at
okay so
what do you think um this is
you know maybe a touchy question um but
you can answer it how you'd like
um what do you think president salovey
should have done in response to
um
let's not say the the ycc statement but
the er m and and women's studies uh
statements what what would um your
advice to him have been to do
right um you know i i'm
hopefully uh
modest in my recommendations of a campus
i haven't been on a long time and in a
situation that i don't know well
i believe
that these issues and you know the the
statement from the first statement is on
the yale website uh the second statement
i pulled off the web
i believe that these issues and these
statements and the issues they raised
rose to the importance uh that a college
administrator should say
look this is problematic from the
institutions stands
this is just uh
over the line
it is not about academic freedom which
is assigned to individuals not programs
or centers
it is about the institution's ability to
conduct its core enterprise intellectual
discourse and i would have recommended
to any president uh who had centers or
programs uh on this that they um
uh that they may clear their opposition
and explain because i think this is an
important moment why this is not in this
case an issue about israel
um i don't think it is uh i don't think
the department of economics should be
issuing statements about how much
deficit spending is appropriate uh even
though i'm sure economists have all
kinds of views about it um it's just not
what college programs should be doing so
i would have advised them to oppose it
um and it's interesting i think that um
in general political science um
departments are really the least likely
to issue these kinds of statements at
least it seems like or to pass you know
bds resolutions it seems um
uh you know i don't know if you could
say something about why you think that
these um
more identity focused programs have been
uh
you know the the ones to do this
i you know
i haven't
been in the debates
uh that these programs had i wasn't part
of the processes uh that were taken
where these votes
where both were taken if votes were
taken
i think it goes back to
what you you asked before
which is
advocacy
and scholarship
in some areas is more uh directly
more directly manifests itself not only
in these areas i have friends who are
constitutional scholars
who are uh
in political science departments who
have their own advocacy for sure of
their own political positions um but
these scholars in both programs take as
part of their intellectual
uh
enterprise
argument political arguments uh that
their program should adopt these
these platforms uh and so that's the
best i can say without being part of
part of the debates themselves yeah i
mean you know my my experience is that
um and i i i was um involved in um
some of the efforts to keep the modern
language association from adopting a
pro-bds
uh platform and i really thought that
was going to pass easily because there
were you know there seemed to be a lot
of you know very strong supporters and
what really emerged was that there were
a lot of very la there was a small group
a relatively small group of very
committed
uh
pro-bds people but that um they were the
ones making the most noise and that in
fact the larger membership of the mla
was was um
not you know so anti-israel and i think
there's some of that you know that that
those voices tend to you know um
be the ones kind of controlling what's
what's going on i don't know if you've
well you know i i i think that's often
the case i
i would say that people who make oh
another manifestation of the problematic
nature of these proclamations is that
you will now be asked your political
opinion on every single issue
what about this what about that uh and
uh some
some programs i think have found
themselves bogged down now
in endless debates about their political
positions
and they should have never gone down
that route in the first place as i said
if individuals want to have
a scholarship and advocacy that's their
business
it's when you invoke institutional
authority that it becomes i think
problematic for the university and
challenging uh for uh supporters and
others on campuses okay and what i don't
know if you can say anything about the
effort to um promote the um working the
so-called working definition of
anti-semitism
as a kind of campus speech code um do
you have any feelings about that
i'm opposed to speech codes uh before we
get even into uh
um
uh the particulars of which definition
of anti-semitism
i think colleges and universities uh
when they start regulating speech uh are
in for trouble um
uh and uh i think it's particularly
inappropriate on a college university
campus
um
what here's a question that i've you
know seen
echoed
and several of the people have asked and
i'll ask in two parts um so first of all
what would you say to
um
parents of
students um
who
many jewish students who supported um
that ycc statement i think there are a
lot of parents who are confused about
you know how jewish students now could
sign on to what seems like an
anti-israel statement so first of all
how do you i'm sure you as the president
of american jewish university might have
some experience and then also um
what you would advise what you would
tell a jewish student on campus now who
feels uncomfortable in the current
situation uh what advice you would give
those are two uh two profound questions
and my children all in their 20s
graduated from college not that long ago
look on the first question
um there are a lot of intergenerational
debates about israel right now
in our society
including among families
i would say talk to your students
take them seriously
don't believe that they've been
brainwashed and understand where they're
coming from
if you disagree with them argue with
them not
in terms of parental authority
but
[Music]
take them
take them seriously
and take their arguments seriously
and
you may find that you reach a meeting of
the minds or you may not uh you know you
can't always reach agreement but i think
uh all relationships are improved when
people take each other seriously
in terms of jewish students and i'll
refer back to the story at the beginning
i tell the guidance counselor who
advised the person the student not to
apply to yale that they were raw
i would say
that's the ultimate victory
uh for the anti-semites
um
that
i first of all i don't believe that
jewish students shouldn't go to yale i
believe they should but i believe that
jewish students like everyone else
should go wherever they want
and should apply to wherever they want
and for the students who are afraid
sometimes legitimately
i'd say
that this is the moment to organize and
to be more forthright about your
political positions and identity to seek
allies on the campus community and with
college administrators
but that
in the end
i believe that anti-semitism will
uh
be furthered
if we try to hide from it uh rather
confront it now i recognize easy for me
to say i occupy a particular position on
a campus
and students
are naturally often conflict averse
afraid to lose friends and alike
but this is the world in which we live
and i think if you can develop
the tools the attitude the mindset to
not only have a set of beliefs but to
feel comfortable with them and not to
feel threatened uh that's an important
set of life skills
okay terrific well this gets us right to
the end of our uh time today um i want
to encourage people to read your great
article um from over the summer and i
think if i don't have the link in front
of me but if you google jeffree herbs
and inside higher ed you'll it'll come
right up um so please you know you're
not gonna be able to uh see all the
clapping hands but um i will do it for
everybody and on behalf of our very
large audience today i want to just say
thank you for taking the time to do this
and for your thoughtful presentation and
i encourage everyone who is here today
to please sign up for the uh ypsa the
ipsa mailing list we have a um a whole
range of very interesting talks planned
for this year and i hope to uh see you
back at a future event so thank you
again jefford thank you so very much
bye bye everybody
you